plus rien ne va nous avons tous échoué
après des heures et des heures des jours
des semaines de réflexion j'en suis
arrivé à cette conclusion il faut
innover sortir des sentiers battus et
tenter des choses nouvelles des choses
fortes des choses radical je pense que
j'ai trouvé une solution
et pour cela j'ai besoin de tous mais
c'est moi s'il vous plaît allez jusqu'au
bout de mon idée je sais que certains
d'entre vous réagir ont brutalement mais
je vous en prie encore une fois laissez
moi aller jusqu'au bout
si on regarde bien la situation on
observe que seuls les juifs s'en sortent
non laissez moi finir laissez moi finir
s'il vous plaît s'il vous plaît
non seulement ils ont de l'argent mais
ils s'entraident ce que j'en déduis ce
que j'en déduis et que je propose est
très simple puisque les juifs sont
riches et qu'ils sont solidaires
devenons tous juifs